if you have expendable cash you'd need
to be a tipper I'm so sorry
there's two people in my life like I
think it's funny that after a week at a
comedy club I'll go up to the manager or
like the owner and just give him a
dollar Wow
Andrew Colin can we just give a
shout-out amazing we went to Andrews
one-man show you got left last night it
was a you up extravagance yeah there was
there was a lot of people there it was
so good yeah it was so good great he is
this picture of him with like a scarf on
hinge like looks like he's like it's a
mindy tucker photo and it's a beautiful
photo you don't like professionally done
but he looks like a gay boy what a
bridge and i'm i come across him on a
hinge because they keep throwing me the
same guys and i keep going no no too
because I'm like I need to have an
intervention with him but this picture
because it is is not who he is and it's
a good photo but it is I gotta pull it
up I'm sure it's the first thing that
comes up when you google him but last
night was fun Ian brought a date
yes how's the date date was good we've
been hanging out a lot after a show at
the South yes and she did a move where
shoot her brother come up and talk to me
and then she tagged him out was like
okay that was my end and she was there
some guy was like hitting on her and in
front of him I went up and wrote my
number on a piece of paper I was like
you should call me and I gave her my
number and we've been hanging out that's
great man yeah that's a good meeting and
she she kind of made the first move
without having to make the you got to
make the first move but she was it's
almost like a bumble meeting where the
girl is like I like you or no no it's
not bumble
yeah bumbles the one where they talk
first but they always say hi and then
they ignore you I don't look like her I
will say I think bumble is a flawed one
because women shouldn't it you know
you've heard me talking about this
goddamn book so many times
here we go listen I'll make it quick but
you got to pick a lane when you're a
woman you either want to be the
masculine role or the feminine role and
either that doesn't if you choose the
masculine role it doesn't mean you like
them guys who are gay it just means it's
just a way of it doesn't matter that you
read the book and if you want to know
the name of the book I'm not gonna tell
you over the air because it's an
embarrassing name but you can Instagram
message me and I will tell you there
anyway
um here's my book you almost sucks for
it bumble sucks you meet you hang out
you do BUTT STUFF and then you love each
other you're developing yeah what's it
called what's but yeah bumbles flawed
because the woman has to reach out first
and it's a-you know Tom met his lady on
Bobo but it worked for you because you
did the exceeded the extent what was the
first move yeah and then she was able to
like say hi or whatever but like I'm uh
I'm on hinge right now and I refused to
make for I refused to say anything first
my hinge looks like somebody just went
into a shelter and was like hey come
here let's take your pictures no not me
my friend is also on it and her dudes
are so it is comically bad I'm like it
looks like you were making up people to
put on a map to troll your friend yes
and in my matches are all dependent on
your Facebook friends and like and on
your lame still it's still like that I
thought that's what I thought but that's
someone just told me it's still like
that and that's probably why hers are
bad because she's not attractive
Facebook friends a reflection on me I
don't know but here's the thing is that
um Anya actually wrote in she likes
showed a drafted email to them being
like why are my matches so unattractive
she needs to know because it is weird
because we all compared our matches and
we're dealing with the same age yeah
that's not okay I get some of those too
Ian just showed me a couple people and
I'm just like if there was a way because
here's the thing in the end any
relationship you see usually you end up
with someone who is within if we're all
1 to 10 scale of attractiveness you
usually end up with someone within two
numbers of you it just happens that way
I can't unless you're a rich old man and
there's a like a young woman there or
like a celebrity guy who's old and rich
it just basic couples they will always
be a couple within two numbers of each
other attractive wise it across the
board give or take I cannot offer I will
beg you to give me an example of
celebrity but it's still not nice no no
but it's a celebrity who's alright it's
not it's not like a it's not like an
unattractive guy it's like a hot guy
okay with a okay listen if I met my high
school sweetheart based on what I looked
like when I was in high school I would
be with an ugly guy now ugly in high
school yeah I didn't figure things out
and you figure some things out I raised
a couple points since high school
mm-hm and that's okay and hopefully he
would raise with me but yeah but yeah
like if you meet someone early on enough
you change a lot and you can you can go
up a couple points they can go down you
can go down they can go up it happens
better go down
[Music]
like a particle and an old boat that is
the truth
we're back it's you up with Nikki Glaser
we're talking about that TED talk I'd
shared yesterday I shared it with Ian
also yesterday via text so you're up to
date with this whole theory about online
dating it's can be overwhelming there's
too many dates you waste too much time
going to dinner with people you keep it
short you at you you set criteria and
you go okay if a guy messages me or a
girl and and they don't and they do
something outside of these three things
for this girl in this TED talk it was
she has to have good grammar he has to
mention something specific in my profile
so that I know it's not a copy and paste
situation and he can't say anything
sexual yes and for that girl those were
her requirements you set your own once
they meet those you agree to a date if
they ask you out or if you're in the
masculine role as a woman you can ask
them out - I don't do that but you wait
for them to ask you out with what you
have to use a gruff voice so then you go
out with them and all you do on the date
it's an hour long you decide whether or
not you want to go to dinner with this
person that's all you determine you
don't go am I gonna walk down the aisle
and see this guy am I gonna have kids
with them do I want to have sex with
them you just go do i when I go to
dinner with him and then you can move it
to dinner and what do you think about it
in I think that's great
getting off line quickly as a way to
yeah that's not real yes you get you get
out of the chat online quickly online
chat is not how it's gonna be oh you
mean and let me tell you guys your your
cock-blocking yourselves the more you
talk like it's happened before where I'm
like oh I would go out with this guy if
he asked me out now and then the
conversation goes maybe three more lines
and I'm like you've already said
something that I'm not interested huh
and it could be a lame joke it can just
be something it can be something that
you didn't even mean to you and I'm
missing out because now I'm judging you
based on this thing that you just in a
moment we're walking and texting and
didn't think and now we've ruined it
yeah yeah like it just anything like I
I'm sure I've said things when the
conversation has gone on too long where
the
guys been like ok I'm not into this
anymore but at what point are you like
hey this is me do you want to get a
coffee no I will tell you the guy that I
went on a date with that I had a great
date the other night I was looking being
like how did we even start chatting like
was it me first I liked one of his
answers on hinge I didn't like a picture
but I'm like yeah I liked one of the
answers I just liked it which is how you
get it started and then he goes he he
referent he wrote him he was the first
to write and he goes believe it or not
this is not in fact the most
embarrassing here oh he was talking
about some he had a joke and I liked it
and he goes but you're going to have to
let me buy you a Seltzer to hear that
story so he referenced that in sober and
he immediately asked me out on a date
and it was before I even responded so it
was like immediate date I loved it I
loved it I the sooner the better
guys because I go hey I think you're
real babe and I'd like to take you love
it here's the only thing you got to put
that specific thing in there no cuz I
was saying that to two people and I was
not getting anything I would just say I
did that a lot when I was drunk I just
met such girls like here babe and I
think they sometimes I would get
messages back but it was not I never
dated anybody from that yeah I think if
he would have said let me I would love
to buy you a drink but he said a seltzer
and I go he he looked at my profile but
I think you're right if he would have
just said you're a babe let me buddy
think I would have been like no yeah I
think that that's that's the key that
you just kind of figured it out because
it was the specific not sexual and asked
me out right away
you say I want to come on yours whatever
part of your cycle you are at when your
tits are this evening
I yeah it's it's it's a delicate balance
cuz I'm in a lot of I'm like in like
probably like ten chats with guys and I
went through yesterday I'm like I can't
keep all of these guys straight there's
too many of them and they all look the
same because I'm into a type and and
they all look like they're like look at
I mean look at this they're all the same
guy Wow all tech guys I got a new match
just now okay it's revealed that his
first picture was good and then you go
for the Dan you okay I see what's going
on with that with the bald cap on Oh
sizing his own brand but yeah I mean all
these apps are kind of the same but I do
like hinge a lot I'm glad that
what's-her-name came in here and told us
about it because it's it's what got me
on there and mine is on hinge
yeah you're not doing well you don't
like it no but I found it real life it's
you're friends with Facebook it's yeah
it's it's it's I'm really enjoying it I
think I'm just I go through different
phases of my life where I'm like oh like
I'm in date phase and right now like I
can do this it won't always be this way
like I will go back into a deep like I
will shut down again and be like I don't
want to meet anyone I don't care I want
to just meet a comedian that already
works in my life right now I'm like let
me take job interview like it feels like
a job interview it feels like kind of
fun like I'm looking for a new job and
the thing is I know job get it I'm like
don't do the joke that I laid out for
everyone to do the thing is I am I don't
know that I'm looking for anything
serious so I think that that's what
makes it fun it's like there's no
expectations on my end mentally to where
you know you're in a good spot to meet
somebody
I had a gonna meet somebody like the
really like from that I think so too I
yeah despite myself you know like not
when you're not looking for essentially
and it's funny because I am looking for
dates but I'm not you setup the
president's in your head this TED talk
completely revolutionized literally the
night before the TED talk that I came
across that I wrote a guy who's been
asking me out on one of these apps for
months and I wrote him and I go listen
you're great you are hot
you seem lovely and like someone I
really have a connection with and it
scares me so that's why I'm not going on
a date with you I want you to know that
I'm genuinely interested in you but I am
not ready for whatever I think this
could be and I'm not saying that you
even want that with me but like your
your greatness scares me and I just I
don't know I was being honest like I was
just like whatever it is like there's I
can't pinpoint why I don't want to go
out with you other than I'm scared
because you seem awesome I'm not ready
and he goes I completely get that I
would so like to just hang out his
friends though and I was like okay
finally the pressures on I think it was
like that plus the TED talk I was like
okay now I'm fine like if I just
approach everything like that where it's
like I I realize I'm scared of true
intimacy huh and I'm trying to get over
that and the only way to force myself to
is to meet more people and open myself
up to it yeah but um I will say that
it's funny like I I was talking to a
friend of mine who went on a date with a
girl recently and he was like you know
we had a great time I thought at dinner
and then afterwards I wanted to like
hang out more and she was like I don't
feel really good and I was listening the
story being like and he goes oh it's
okay that you're nothing like do you
want to maybe instead of just doing
going do send just go back to my place
we could just watch TV and she's like
I'm gonna go home and then he found out
that she like didn't go home she went
out with friends and like he found out
from the friend that's about that it
wasn't she wasn't into it and he was
like bummed and I go but and my friend
is awesome uh-huh and I was like she
doesn't get it dude
yeah she doesn't get it so she doesn't
get it yeah she did you a favor and by
the way this curl sounds lame AF because
you are so cool it's like you wouldn't
you
want to be with she's bad taste and he
was like whoa you just like changed the
way I feel but this enough and I did my
girlfriend the other day too and I was
like this guy that you're pining for he
has bad taste I wouldn't want to hang
out with him because he doesn't like my
friend who is the most amazing after you
and you're the greatest person like he's
flawed yeah I wouldn't wanna hang out
with him he doesn't know greatness but
he doesn't even want to be your friend
uh-huh then he sucks yeah and so I've
been spouting all this kind of yes yeah
and and I and I really believe that like
I don't think the bet person is a bad
person they just not someone I would
want to be friends if they liked movies
I don't like probably they just a bad
taste in my opinion of people and things
sure so then I went on a date a couple
nights ago with this guy the guy that
was talking about that it was like the
we were talking about statistics and
like it was a very intellectual
conversation and he was so hot and and
at the end of it I was like like I don't
know if I'll want to go I might want to
go out with him again if he asks but
like he'll definitely want to go out
with me again because I killed it I'm
beautiful I like I I'm going blazes
Church and Nikki Glaser's yeah I was
just like he's definitely gonna want to
go out and I'll have to decide whether
or not I follow up with us sure and then
I didn't hear from him and I was like oh
he wasn't feel like he wasn't feeling me
and then suddenly I was forced to give
myself my own advice yeah which was if
he doesn't get it then he doesn't get it
and he's doing me a favor by not having
me have to reject him yeah and now I
know that he's doesn't get it yeah but
then he then he wrote me a letter so I
guess it was pretty great
I was like I knew it I know I go from my
breaks every person that I've yeah that
book does not let me just say the book
doesn't suck yeah the book when you give
a guy eight weeks
wouldn't you say to a guy here's what I
want if you know this is what the book
is good for if you like a guy and he
just wants to hang out and keep things
casual and he doesn't want to lock you
down as a girlfriend and you want to be
his girlfriend saying to a guy that's
what I want and I don't want anything
less is a great idea because it forces
his hand because you don't want to
settle either girl so it does and over
the eight weeks that you give him to
either realize that he wants to be with
you or not and he doesn't come around in
that eight weeks you realize that you
don't really need him yeah so it is a
group the book is I think there I'm not
saying every facet of the books
yes but I'm saying that's the good part
okay that I agree with at that time is a
towel anyway but Dave Attell huh that's
true yeah I know every single person
that like you've ever been rejected by
if you think about what it would have
been like to date them in the past
you're like oh that would have sucked
yes I was like what first of all the guy
that was telling me about this girl I'm
like you're way hotter than her like the
only reason you want her is because she
did those never seemed into you I talked
to him before the date and he was like I
don't know she just seems like someone I
have to like really like win over and
I'm like you know this is we're gonna
where I go this girl is perfect for you
because that's all you want is people
who don't want you and then he pulled up
a picture I'm like she's not even ki
like as cute as you like everyone just
water because doesn't want you yeah yeah
but that when someone wants me I'm like
what's wrong with you yeah of course
because you don't love yourself I do
know we're all working on it that's
that's my whole point is that I used to
hate myself so I only wanted guys who
like truly hated me like didn't respect
me at all
I only wanted guys who didn't like me
cuz I didn't like myself now I'm working
towards loving myself I'm not there yet
but I like myself so I can like people
that like me which is a vast improvement
upon guys who don't like me so I like
guys who like me but do I love guys
love me not yet I'm working towards it
I'm getting there you're getting there I
have all the potential to love myself
I'm clearly on my way but I am not there
yet because when I see a guy that I'm
like this guy has the capacity to love
another person and is in a place it
scares me so much because I don't truly
in my heart of hearts feel like I
deserve it yet and I know I do on paper
I'm trying to get there and that's why I
go to therapy that's why I read
self-help books that's why I do
meditation that's why I do positive
affirmations you go to the mountains
yeah I mean yeah I mean you went to the
mountains you isolated yourself in a
yurt yeah last weekend tell me about it
it was incredible yeah turn my phone off
I went out in nature I didn't do I had
like a mushroom trip without the
mushrooms Wow is incredible I spend time
with self I reflected I read a book in
two days when I'm in the city I can't
even read because everything's like I
had my I turned my phone off guess what
nobody's calling ya you really don't
know the news cycle kind of stays the
same I would get notifications of my
thing that was like yeah it was just
like me in nature breathing yeah and I
went on a hike and I set a goal to hike
and I did it and I didn't use anyone to
like go with me and I don't know it was
just very nice to breathe and get out of
the city and achieve this thing that I
wanted to do and be with self for myself
and for the things around me because I
went two days without anything around me
yeah I think the only way I'm gonna be
able to do that is to get arrested and
then go into solitary confinement and be
forced into murder self literally and
then misbehave in Britain go into the
hinge killers yeah okay yeah they're
already that I'm like I'd like to murder
and they're so boring no one will miss
them no I think there already is a hinge
killer I'm sure oh there's gotta be
there's gotta be considered a copycat
yeah going out in the woods I mean I
really admire you for doing that because
it takes a lot to unplug and I don't
know that I'm much like loving myself I
don't know that I'm
yet I detected to my phone I don't think
I could do it I I have that negative
thing in my head it like tells you mr.
stupid I suck and all this stuff and I
really have to combat it yeah and I I
was in complete silence on the road out
on the ride up got into the cabin
complete silence alone in a cabin and
the first thing I said out loud is I'm
not stupid
negative boy are you okay
sometimes I'll yell things out cuz I'm
having an argument oh yeah I went on the
edge of a mountain and yelled into the
wilderness positive affirmations
[Music]
you